did you know that you can now search
every moment of every video file in your
catalog google cloud video intelligence
quickly annotates videos stored in
Google Cloud storage and helps you
identify key nouns within your video and
when they occur within the video on this
episode of Google cloud labs we'll
introduce you to a quick lab that shows
you how cloud video intelligence makes
video searchable and discoverable by
extracting metadata with an easy-to-use
REST API you'll create a request file
and call the video intelligence API to
create an operation to process your
request you will run the operation when
it's complete you can see your videos
annotated helping you identify key
entities within the video cloud video
intelligence allows you to extract
actionable insights from video files
without requiring any machine learning
or computer vision knowledge from our
massive library of 20,000 labels it
automatically analyzes video content to
identify what entities are in your video
content and when they appear cloud video
intelligence improves over time as new
concepts are introduced and accuracy is
improved this lab is part of a series of
labs called quick starts these labs are
designed to give you a little taste of
the many features available within
Google Cloud search for quick starts in
the lab catalog to find a next lab you'd
like to take when you're ready use this
link to take the lab we just went
through today and when you're ready to
sign up for GCP use this link to apply a
three hundred dollar credit to your
account we want to hear from you every
week we'll answer a question from our
viewers so let us know what's on your
mind in the comments below
[Music]